[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday April
something I'm in Washington there's wind
turbines
I think wooden turbines are pretty but a
lot of people seem to think that wind
turbines are ugly and so they don't want
to put them along bridges I don't
understand that the third it's it's the
third we went to Seattle to see some
friends and for no other reason besides
that well we also wanted to see a comedy
show and you know eat some real food and
do things that you can only do in a big
city like drive yeah there's a lot of
driving
so the Space Needle from a car one of
the awesomest parts of Seattle is the
public market which is sort of a three
story deep market with all kinds of
strange things in it like there's street
performers and there's fish with stuff
in their mouths and people throw in fish
throw in fish around like crazy Watson
and then there's this girl and she asked
if they'd ever hit somebody with a fish
in these not on purpose she didn't
believe them so she showed her and then
there was this doughnut making machine
which was awesome and obviously has been
there longer than Krispy Kreme has ever
existed and this guy who was just a
wizard with donuts I tell you I wizard
I'm pretty sure that there aren't very
many donut wizards but this guy is
pretty much the definition of donut
wizard
they were really good doughnuts too
so I gotta say thanks to everybody in
Seattle everybody that's that's
everybody if there's any of you watching
thanks Seattle is a great town on top of
that special thanks go to Ashley Jason
Brian and Becca for showing us around
the town and giving us a place to sleep
and letting us play their video game was
an awesome weekend and I need an awesome
weekend I'm back home and facing
punishment you know you can have the
best job in the world
but some days you will wake up and you
won't want to go to work
that's just what work is no one would
pay you to do something that you just do
anyway this morning I woke up and I'm
very sorry to you John to all of our
viewers I didn't want to make a video I
wanted to lay in bed all day we had a
really bad drive home the pass was
pretty much covered in two inches of ice
and it was very stressful even though I
wasn't even driving yeah Thank You
Catherine oh my god yeah this morning I
just I wanted to stay in bed we'd had
too much fun this weekend and I didn't
want to get up I didn't want to do it I
didn't want to make TV I wanted to watch
TV and I did I watched a little bit of
TV and it was good and now I'm I'm up
and I'm going and I'm making a video you
know I'm doing it I'm showing you what
happened in Seattle and that's good
footage that's good stuff and I'm making
it and you know what I'm happy about it
I'm glad that I kicked myself out of bed
to do it even though it's like 6 o'clock
in the evening now thank you to the one
person who has stuck up for me and given
that $10 to the campaign to decrease
suck levels worldwide that was very kind
but there's only one of you and I need
19 more before we can really get me off
the hook here so I'd like to see those
start rolling in and if not I'm gonna
have to figure out a punishment to do
for Thursday obviously I haven't figured
out which punishment I'm going to do
you're all just going to have to wait
and see John I'll see you tomorrow